going to ask you just to say your first
name just one time for me Destiny Edward
Brendan have you ever been in so much
pain that you went into doubt if it
would ever end yes and did it bring you
a lot of doubt I did at times in life I
guess sure yeah okay and when we talk
about like feeling like a victim what
exactly does that mean to you I guess
not having control over traumatic
situations you you struck me as a very
independent person and yes but did you
ever feel that you were victimized to
some point I don't know not that I can
think of but I'm like rethinking
everything in life like maybe I've made
my decision after looking at the
energetic patterns of information I've
been able to I believe determine who has
had the botched surgery